[Music]
all right up next is tashay from buffalo
welcome to the show
hi thank you absolutely how can we
so i'm help upside down on my car loan
um it was originally a 72
term loan
i have 25 payments left to make on the
car
my monthly payments are 359
each month
uh the kelly blue book value for the car
is forty nine hundred dollars and right
now i owe ten thousand five hundred
dollars on the car
so yes i'm very upside down you roll
another car into this purchase
no i didn't
how did it get so
how did it get so upside down i haven't
heard that at all in the last 24 months
so the original loan amount was for
fourteen thousand dollars and my
interest rate is twenty point two
percent
when i got the loan i honestly was a
little bit younger and i really needed a
car quick because my last vehicle was
totaled i had gap coverage my insurance
paid the whole thing out
so i kind of just didn't look at the
terms i looked at the monthly payment
and saw i could afford it and that was
it yikes
so we learned we learned our lesson
right
oh yeah
never never again
um
i'm 26. okay hey
i learned this lesson at like 38. you
won okay so you'll never do it again
it's a ten or five to ten thousand
dollar
uh
let's celebrate that for what it is is
that cool
cool yeah all right it is what it is and
we're gonna move forward on it
but uh i am right stick to my stomach
for you yep okay so
so
what what's your income what do you make
a year
um right now i make 32 but i just
accepted a new position that starts um
in august for 39. okay um and i'm doing
gig work outside of that as much as i
can how much do you think you'll make
doing that
um
probably 45 000 between the job and okay
uh gig work yeah that's great okay
and what other debt do you have besides
this car loan
i do have student loans i have 22 000 of
student loans
and then i also have 8 000 of credit
card debt i'm using the snowball method
to pay off okay
that you're using what to pay off what
did you just say
the snowball
okay yes i've already
yeah i've paid a couple cards off
already so i just have the one did you
have a big one that's 8 000. okay do you
have any savings
um i have five hundred dollars in
savings okay um but the car keeps being
repaired every month so it's kind of
eating away at the savings yep
absolutely okay i'm gonna i'm gonna keep
you on the line because i wanna circle
back okay so
for where you're at in the car so you're
saying it and it needs repairs
consistently
yeah so in the last three months i have
spent um 350 at least every single month
for the past three months
and i just want to sell the car at this
point and trying to figure out if that's
the best thing to do
or what's wrong with it
um they say it's normal wear and tear so
just new wheels new tires
getting brakes fixed and things like
that it's just all kind of happening one
after another i suppose
usually
here's what i don't want you to do i
don't want you to get annoyed with a car
that's got regular maintenance stuff on
it and just get so frustrated you just
sell it and then put yourself in a hole
um
i understand if it's if you're telling
me the transmission's going out and then
the alternator's broken and we're having
some real problem like
then there's some systemic issues with
the car if you've had a of just a really
bum run of luck the last three or four
months you got to change this and change
this get the brakes
then man then i'd say
just bite down on your mouthpiece get in
there and swing a few more months and
hang on to this thing you know what i
mean
right yes
yeah so looking at your numbers and
everything i mean
one option is yeah you sell the car
you take out a five thousand dollar
loan for the difference and then
you are where you are with no car
so that's not a great option because
you're gonna need a car so you could
pause the debt snowball save up a ton of
cash go get a fifteen hundred dollar car
crappy car that's gonna get you here or
there but it's reliable
and you're going to drive it for for
eight months save up some more cash on
the side a little bit sell it replace
you know keep moving up slowly
um that could be the option
or
uh knock out this credit card debt
work like insane hours like i'm talking
like 60 hours a week you have two extra
jobs you just go nuts on this
and pay off the credit card the 8 000
and
the car the 10 000 car loan that you
have currently
um and then look to see okay can i sell
can i sell it after that so those are
really the two the two options and
both kind of get you where you're at now
if you
hate the car and you're just like oh
would you rather
yeah take out the difference in a loan
put that and be paying that off because
that's gonna be smaller than even your
credit card
eight thousand dollar bill
and
go drive a crappier car but could have
maintenance too right so i mean that's
yeah
we're never going to tell you you should
go
take out a car alone
okay
and get out of this mess like i i
like as rachel as you were saying that
it sounds like
the next three or four years of trading
and hanging on and doing some repairs
and then
upgrading a car to get right back to
this same 4900 car
right
i'd rather see you pause the baby steps
and just
repair this thing get it knocked out so
that's going to keep you going for the
next 24 months or something 18 months
right uh paul i'd rather you just stop
and get this thing taken care of and
then just say this is gonna be my car
for a while i am upside down i signed um
i made a bad deal and we're just gonna
hammer this because really the math that
we always say is if you can't pay the
car off in 18 to 24 months then you need
to sell it
but the 10 000 to where you're at i
think you're i think you're going to pay
it off i think you could
went
which went bananas yeah and that's the
other thing is is in this season of the
debt snowball and all of it i know it
feels like setback you know when you
have these repairs and all of that
but man if you if you can just
you know make another 20 grand
25 grand a year doing extra stuff part
time you know three or four nights
that you're out you know driving uber
eats whether it's that or it's walking
dogs like i don't care what it is but
it's amazing what people are paying now
for jobs oh yeah and labor than what
they were even 12 months ago i mean like
what you can make
doing things and even getting creative i
mean i've heard people now are renting
out their backyard so it's like an app
to run out your backyard for like a
party or something and so people are
doing that for a night and making like
400 bucks and it's like
sure why not i mean i don't know the
last uber ride i took the
guy just on the way to work flips on his
light and he says i just make an extra
50 to 100 bucks on the way to work and
then on the way home and i just pick up
somebody in my neighborhood who's going
to the airport or something yeah and he
leaves 20 or 30 minutes early and so
there's it's a matter of figuring out
and it's also the other side of the
equation
you cannot eat out for the next 12
months you cannot buy another item of
cloth like you got to shut down spending
and get this stuff this is scary broke
stuff this is scary stuff you're not
safe let's get this stuff paid off yeah
so the expensive side of your life is
going to be really important cutting
everything back and then upping that
income but yeah but when it comes to the
car i know it's frustrating but what you
were hearing even it's kind of normal
repairs
if that's my sister that's me that's me
i would take that car to a mechanic that
i trust and say what's it going to cost
out the door to get this thing up to
where it needs to go
like wheels tires brakes what give me a
price across the board what's it gonna
cost and then i'm gonna pause the baby
steps for a few months save that money
up and go get it all done so then i can
drive this thing on and i'm gonna
let that rage and that anger like i hate
this car i hate this car i hate this car
that's gonna propel you to work those
crazy hours and those wild jobs and get
this thing paid off and move on